alors maintenant on va parler on va
parler nenê on a parlé gros nichons avec
philippe guérin merci 15 raciale et
c'est ce qu'il faut dans cette semaine
on a décidé de faire une enquête un
sondage en mai un sondage d'un nouveau
type tannourine regarder naître en
allemand une camionnette
on a pris une comédienne françoise
huguet qu'il faut ça ouais on s'est dit
au lieu de tester des yaourts au lieu de
tester des peintures on va tester dès
nenê ouais et puis regardez ce que ça
donne bonjour monsieur je réalise un
sondage sur les produits de beauté vous
auriez un petit moment pour sacrer oui
c'est très très gros et alerte wallon un
acier mais je vous en prie merci enfin
toute cette étude on m'a demandé donc de
m'épiler les gens de deux façons une
avec un rasoir et une avec de la crème
[Rires]
bon en gros ce soir c'est voulu la plus
sexy beaucoup de gens font sexy
maintenant à faire la même chose avec un
produit pour la poitrine et je vais vous
demander lequel de mes deux seins et
plus ferme
oui mais habitait foug pas une raison
pour avis pour peu mettra forcément
général limites non mais pour le j'aime
toucher
bah oui je sais mais c'est ça qui en fit
le coureur ne s'est pas possible
histoire
tu vas voir c'est vrai que j'ai envie
touché mais je vais vous demander lequel
est le plus doux le
et de vous souhaiteriez le plus emporté
chez vous bonjour et moi je suis entre
les rails jeanne mas bien oui c'est
bientôt fini
vous avez fait combien de questionnaires
14 c'est bien qu'elle va continuer je
regarde ça se passe bien le plus doux
je voudrais rappeler le vert monsieur a
réussi aussi vous faites bien toucher là
monsieur touché sur l'isi le plus beau
les [__] on en fait toutes ces
questions soient sa rotation parce que
le plus beau si une ou et
vous en connaissez aux enquêtés de
toucher la poitrine dont catherine entre
chaque question que ce que vous ne
faites pas on verra justement après
celui là j'arrête
alors le plus ton temps
elite 2 mais plus sexy
oui
celui que vous souhaitez y est le plus
important chez vous
ouais quitté journée le docteur gros
bonjour vous venez d'écrire un livre
s'appelle le saint des voix et c'est
chez qui je stocke chez stock
oui la collection laurence pernoud
laurence pernot qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce sujet là comment vous
réagissez sur ces gens qui vivent dans
des camionnettes pour toucher les seins
samedi après-midi sur un parking
d'hypermarché
non je crois qu'il touche pas vraiment
du sens ils savent pas bien touché il
nous touche du bout du bout des doigts
et puis touche pas vraiment un saint il
touche un peu plus une partie anthony
féminines c'est un sens complètement des
fantasmes et je trouve l'imaginé on n'a
pas le temps de la mode est vide
vous touchez pas comme ça avance et plus
je touche les patientes de retoucher
effectivement sans crainte de l'énergie
ça vous arrive quand même de faire
intervenir l'imaginaire quand vous cache
une passion absolue non le requin
faisaient leur métier que vous faites
pas vous êtes cette sinologue non mais
ce n'est là c'est à dire que je m'occupe
donc de toucher de sa de famille et pas
seulement de toucher de les deviner mais
vous savez il ya une espèce d'éducation
de réflexes et pas quand on quand on
voit des femmes et quand on les examine
justement le regard devient
tout à fait dépouiller et je crois que
tu peut paraître étonnant mais on ne
voit plus le simple organe érotique on
voit le st une femme qui vient pour 1/3
plage c'est très sérieux parce que vous
faites venir le mari qui surveille
avant je ne me pose jamais ce que le
mari viennent ya des femmes qui
souhaitent que leur mari viennent
d'autres questions cause tout à fait
mais je trouve qu'il marie envie de
venir avec ninon du mois en cours pour
en revenir au sujet donc vous pensez que
les gens quand on les fait monter dans
une camionnette pour toucher des saints
comme ça ils savent pas bien faire quoi
ils ont pas le tueur ils sont dans ses
déboires je prends l'impression que les
personnes qui sont passées à la
camionnette doivent toucher les hommes
en tout cas il a touché le sein de leurs
fans comme ils le feront de la
camionnette alors se serait-il un très
triste pour l'état
alors vous voulez de monsieur vous êtes
vous êtes sémiologue dire que vous êtes
le deuxième sénologue de france puisque
votre père était le premier et il
s'appelait charles data peschard le
groupe pour aller chercher le gros c'est
lui qui a inventé cette la sénologie
c'est de la chesnaie la pression parce
que je crois que vous étiez new look de
père en fils dans la famille il se
trouve que effectivement j'ai épousé son
intérêt pour la pole d'accord alors moi
il ya un passage que j'ai adoré dans
votre livre c'est sony que kerry et moi
on a le plus plu c'est le passage sur le
sein des hommes ah oui après tout je
veux dire les seins des femmes c'est
bien ça fait tous adulé puis à ça pour
les hommes c'est un petit peu dur
est ce que les saints des hommes sondés
des organes sexuels super multi vous
dites est à considérer le 5 comme un
organe sexuel et vous expliquer que le
mamelon durci il ya une rougeur yak
comment vous dites qu en tant qu'enjeu
la femme montre 105 sa rougir la peine à
rethel effectivement la mairie
c'est ça c'est la rougeur et +10
méritait mieux certaines fin des
festivités n'est rien ou de quelques-uns
on va pas consultation il ya des petites
taches rouges qui apparaissent l'année
son décolleté laissant échapper la
couleur de la vertu qui est défendu est
ce que les hommes ont des érythèmes
pudica par philippe ça on est en prêt
j'en ai jamais vu c'est sûr que c'est
fonction de l'investissement qu'elle a
moins souvent quelque chose de thierry
c'est qu'ils se peut que tu puisses à
jour à l'été non aille urs c'est
difficile d'affirmer gagnent plus
arrêter ce concert u2 était d'esprit
psion d'hommes pour aller dans
l'histoire - yves arrive de voir des
hommes qui viennent consulter parce
qu'elles ont prises ont une vie des
raisons évoquées henry lapsus révélateur
jacques et écoulement ou via une un sac
qui s'est développée donc le saint
masculin est un symbole féminin en
miniature il est où l'abbé bail et de
temps en temps il peut être stimulé et
obus mesdames si vous voulez faire à
l'été vos enfants par thierry ardisson
des corrections de ne rien rater de
finale andy tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus